- [Narrator] What we're
gonna do in this video
is describe how our
perceptions of public opinion
may, or may not, affect policy decisions.
So what I have here is an
excerpt from an article
on Politico that was published
at the end of February.
Shortly after the shootings in Florida.
And it says, support for
stricter gun laws has spiked
in polls conducted after
the fatal South Florida
school shooting, hitting its highest level
in at least a quarter-century.
Roughly two in three Americans
now say gun control laws
should be made more strict
in the wake of the murder
of 17 people at Marjory
Stoneman Douglas High School.
According to a number of polls,
including a new Politico,
Morning Consult, poll that shows support
for stricter gun laws among
registered voters at 68%,
compared with just 25% who
oppose stricter gun laws.
So if there was just a direct connection
between what we're seeing
in the polls and policy,
well then you might
expect stricter gun laws.
And you can imagine, there
are many policy makers
who are already in support
of the stricter gun laws,
who would use this data
to further their argument
why State Congress should
pass more legislation
to make stricter gun laws.
But an interesting question
is why this still might be
an uphill battle in terms
of making stricter gun laws.
Well, you could imagine there
are other policy makers,
members of Congress, who
one, they may or may not
trust the poll data here.
Maybe they don't view it as a
truly representative sample.
Others might say, "Hey,
this is a temporary trend
"that's driven by the graphic nature
"of the news surrounding these polls."
Others might say,
"Hey look, this might
be the national numbers,
"I believe this poll."
And it might not even
be a temporary trend,
but they say, "This is
representative of the entire country.
"The polling numbers in my
district might be different."
Now another reason why a policy maker,
despite this type of national poll,
may not want to vote in
favor of stricter gun laws,
is that their political
calculus might not favor it.
For example, even if they're constituents
support stricter gun laws,
most of their constituents
might not be so activated about that.
They might care more about
things like the economy.
And they might have a smaller subset,
say the 25% who oppose stricter gun laws,
who are willing to vote on that issue.
And it might do more harm
to your political chances
to upset that group on this issue,
then to try to appeal to
the majority on the issue.
And the last reason why a policy
maker may not be in support
of it, even though public
opinion seems to be,
is that they view the
issue as being more subtle
and more nuance then maybe they think
that the broader public might appreciate.
That yes, when you see
something horrific like this
you want to regulate it
more, you want to pass laws,
but there could be
policy makers who believe
that those laws won't be affective,
or they might not have
the intended consequences.
But it's an interesting question,
when public opinion
affects policy decisions,
and when it doesn't.